david do you think washington dc's
strict gun laws saved lives
during the trump riot this is a very
interesting question
it's really a question that has to be
thought about in large numbers and what
i mean by that is
statistically dc's gun laws almost
certainly saved some lives let me
uh talk talk through my sense of it and
if you disagree with me just let me know
i know that the gun people often say
gun laws don't stop any crimes because
the criminals don't follow the laws
anyway
the criminals will find an illegal way
to get a gun
the criminals will bring guns where they
aren't allowed anyway
so it doesn't make a difference and
certainly anecdotally that may well be
true to some degree that may well be
true
but there are certainly some
insurrectionists who opted to leave
their firearms at home
who if the laws were laxer
in dc would have brought guns with them
some of them certainly had guns with
them we know that
but the number of guns was certainly
lower because of washington dc's gun
laws as a result of that
there are certainly some people who if
they had had firearms with them on that
day in washington dc
could have been uh ending up in some
kind
of a confrontation where either they
would have
taken out drawn or used their firearm
or police may have used one against them
by virtue of seeing that some of these
individuals were
armed so were there people in the
capital with guns
probably yeah probably they were some
would the number have been higher
were the gun laws way more relaxed than
washington dc yeah i think it's
undeniable that more people would have
had guns
and reducing the number of guns in the
situation
removes lowers the probability that
there would have been more
of an escalation now i know that there
are lots of people saying david a lot of
the people did have guns and they didn't
they didn't use them they didn't draw
them
that's fine but it's merely a numbers
game if you introduce way more guns
into people involved in violent
confrontations physical scuffles shoving
matches and the like
the odds that a gun comes out just goes
up by by virtue of the number of guns
that are that are around
um the the other thing that i think is
important to mention
is a lot of the way that this went down
and there was a very delayed you know we
we we're learning about
the stand down orders that have been
uncovered and a lot of different things
but
another aspect to this is that for a
while on january 6th
there was the perception from many
including many in law enforcement that
this was going to be just another trump
rally now they had plenty of reasons to
know it was going to be more than that
and we're exploring whether that was
ignored or
what directives were given but to some
degree some of the people
involved around the event thought this
was just going to be another trump rally
and that probably early on also led to
the lack of response that we saw
had there been more of a response early
on
and more guns around i think that
without a doubt
the odds of a gun escalation go go up
dramatically
unfortunately there wasn't and i do
think that some role
some role was dc's gun laws and there
are many many ways in which
those gun laws to many people did not
make a difference